This is your reminder that the holiday season is coming up,
and we are looking at gift guides for her.
Right. Okay.
Women like to feel thought of,
considered, and we love a pampering gift.
So if you have a coastal grandmother or a mom in your life,
I would go ahead and get her this bundle set from Old Whaling Company.
It is a body butter, a soap,
and a bath bomb all in one with a matching set.
This one is Floral Coast. It smells like hydrangeas at the beach.
So fully coastal grandmother.
Absolutely luxurious.
It comes in a beautifully little packaged gift bag.
Gift box. Go ahead and get that at TikTok Shop.
It'll come straight to your house,
and your wife will think that you went through a lot of effort.